hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
and I just checking in on you check it
in to see how your week is going shot
out to all the economies that are
starting to open up you know we'll see
how it goes
shout out to the Cheesecake Factory out
there and somewhere in Texas the Wow and
that Botox clinic down there in Orange
County
they're all gonna fall on the knife for
the rest of us I don't know if this is
true this is just I don't watch the news
this is just [ __ ] people on the phone
have told me all right and I know
there's a lot of commercials because
I've been watching a lot of TV I know
there's a lot of commercials out there
thanking everybody we want to thank all
the what do they call them necessary
workers out there surprised it hasn't
been any push back you know to say that
some people are necessary and other
people aren't necessary makes some of
most people are gonna be feeling
unnecessary and during these uncertain
times you know the one great thing about
all of this [ __ ] has been it kind of
shut up all of the well I guess now then
us they're kind of going again with the
whole brave thing you know these people
who are during this thing going to work
and making money well thank you to all
of them all in the Sessa teenis
necessary people you know but it's
always sexy jobs isn't it right who do
they give a shout-out to right now the
doctors and the nurses i'll banging each
other with their [ __ ]
Kovach scrubs on you know live in a
miniseries some a-list movie stars gonna
play one of them doctor we're out of
beds oh god damn it throw a pillow on a
radiator I don't give a [ __ ] I got
patients to treat this summer Josh GAD
is Joe Sixpack doctor what was it like
to play Joe six-pack doctor well you
know just I mean I'm just an actor these
are like the real heroes I don't know
why I find all of those commercials
thanking them [ __ ] a guilt trip you
know to me I'm sitting there watching
but I they [ __ ] make me annoyed what
a surprise bill what like what does it
annoy you well maybe that's how I can
talk to myself for the whole podcast all
right there has to be a sacrifice
somewhere and I yeah they're like
bugging me I'm just thinking like at
what point was I not appreciative of
[ __ ] doctors and nurses and firemen
and all of that Jesus Christ with the
thanked and then a thanking or am i
super imposing the guilt trip that
they've put on the support the troops
thing so no one will start it up and be
like well hey aren't you real yeah
you're really over there to free the
Iraqi people or aren't you really over
there to get the goop out of the ground
there
considering you won't help fellow
Americans in Flint Michigan and [ __ ] it
ah Jesus
anyway shout-out to Isaiah Thomas man I
felt bad [ __ ] making fun of that guy
in the last podcast because then I saw
him he must have been getting a ton of
[ __ ] cuz he went on TV and tried to
change the narrative of that story ain't
goin like he went about it the wrong way
Bill Laimbeer crushed it cuz I say it
was on TV goin you know I did every
level
reading his resume you know academically
scholastically spelling-bee sports the
Olympic team in 1980 I made a diorama in
the fourth grade that went first prize
he went the whole [ __ ] way and he
goes if it comes down to a lapse and
emotional he still couldn't say that he
[ __ ] up he still couldn't say you
already threw the Celtics out of the bus
and if I didn't get on that team because
of a handshake then it hurts even more
today he went white check on this it
hurt even more today right smash cut to
Bill Laimbeer hey are you upset that you
made that decision because it seemed
like it was your idea to walk off the
court he goes now [ __ ] those guys well
we want it they said we weren't real
champions Bill Laimbeer crushed it just
like every time he was at the top of the
key he'd always hit that [ __ ] shot
swish nothing but net on that one
anyway I just been continuing on
watching old NFL I've been doing that
and then I've been watching the reels
man breaking the band it's been my
favorite trashy show and I got this
their whole like whatever you call that
a little slug line or some [ __ ] they
just talk about how difficult it is to
be in pants in every episode and then
they go the bigger the band and then I
yell at my TV I go do you know what I
love about the reals breaking the band
is there's so few actual band members in
it and if you get an actual band member
it's usually the side man or the guy who
got kicked out so then you know it's
gonna be like extra meow
although the journey one the journey one
had some
a couple of actual members in the
journey one was great
it had everything it had the manager
being like I put this whole [ __ ]
thing together you know he had the
prodigy guitar player was it Niels Shawn
[ __ ] guy played at Woodstock it like
[ __ ] he was like 13 15 years old or
some [ __ ] right and I gotta listen to
early journey I guess they were like all
fusion and all of that [ __ ] and then
Steve Perry comes in and they totally
switched the direction they're going in
they start making all of this [ __ ]
money and then Niels Shawn wants to
still rock man and Steve Perry wants to
sing some ballads man and then like that
that pulled the whole [ __ ] thing
apart or started to I don't [ __ ] know
I don't know if they came down pretty
hard on Steve Perry though but it's also
reels so I think they just decide
because reels also ended Led Zeppelin
saying that the letter that Led Zepplin
wrote left it open-ended it was kind of
vague it's like no it wasn't vague it
was the defendant at the fin ative
statement we're done we won't be the
same because John bought him such a
great [ __ ] drummer we can't carry on
as we were and that was it and other
than a couple of benefits and when the
guy from Atlantic Records passed away
they haven't and they could make
hundreds of zillions of dollars on the
road but evidently Robert Plant invested
his money in real estate so he doesn't
need the [ __ ] money so he's all good
which is why all freckles in my final 18
years as a comedian I'm walking at 70
this is what I'm saying hope I am I'm
not gonna walk but I mean I want to be
able to I am going to become a slumlord
mark my words I will go down as one of
the biggest slum Lords in all of
rental unit history shout-out to the
Crenshaw mall
I guess that's closing is being turned
into office space so there's a big
debate about whether or not it's because
of gentrification because of the
pandemic flu or because of Em's Amazon
the China flu
why don't they find the name of the
first patient just if you're gonna get
that just get really specific Thank You
Kim Fong you for eating that goddamn bat
anyway yet so the you know everybody
orders [ __ ] off a [ __ ] Amazon nobody
wants to go outside certainly during a
pandemic but even before then you know
what I mean I think you could be mostly
gentrification and then I think the
other aspect is the food industry and
they turned our food into [ __ ] poison
and then people eat it and then they
just get too [ __ ] lethargic and out
of shape to leave the house so then they
call Amazon I like when you order
something off at Amazon and they sent it
in a giant box like that's how [ __ ]
much business that doing we're out of
little boxes anyway I did some more
research of old NFL and now AFL stuff
and I can't get enough of this [ __ ] I
bought some old football cards I've been
watching all this old NFL film I watched
this whole thing on the the Vikings in
the the Colts in like 1968 I was
watching this game and they the giant
sorry the Vikings had this guy joke cap
it's like the first Latino quarterback
right
who fit
his career with the Boston Patriots he
came over our way and then he was there
for it was the first Latino quarterback
I believe in the NFL and he won the Rose
Bowl MVP or something in 1958 I already
talked about this and then they didn't
draft him of course like he got a B
whole watt to play that position so we
had to go to the [ __ ] CFL crush every
record up there the same way Warren Moon
had to [ __ ] 20 years after that and
he came back down and he was known for
his toughness and he played for the
Vikings for like three four seasons and
then I believe they brought Fran
Tarkenton back Fran played like four
years for the Vikings then played like
another four years or something for the
Giants then they brought him back so
then he went on a big trade he went over
to the Boston Patriots and we were
getting this veteran you know CFL
hall-of-famer I mean he was tough guy
right he had the one bar mask and then
the Patriots drafted Jim Plunkett and he
was like what the [ __ ] and held out and
then I that was just sort of the end of
his career forget there was this other
guy Gary kawazu when he left or
something
so I read up on who's this Gary quasi
guy he had you know amazing football
career as anybody who made it into the
NFL collegiate career and all of that
[ __ ] then I read this sad story of how
his now he goes around he does all these
speaking things to try to keep kids off
drugs cuz his kid get involved in that
stuff and actually get murdered it was
just like Jesus well that's a nice fun
story well sorry I just been going
around the league but happened to
haven't gone back and looked at all of
those champions and then the AFL
champions you know I got a buddy of mine
is like a Cleveland Brown fans and he's
always [ __ ] whining oh good phryges
so hard to be a Bugaboo it's like
there's other people in front of you all
right
the date to date the Detroit Lions ain't
won it since 1957
the Cleveland Browns won an NFL title in
64 and then they wanted in 2000 and then
like 2012 they were the Ravens but it
was that franchise so the city of
Cleveland has had a football drought
since 1964 however the Lions have gone
since 57 the Cincinnati Bengals have
never wanted they've been around since
like what the 60s
Paul Browns [ __ ] Bengals saw a quit
she [ __ ] cry in Cleveland I'm really
basing this off of like two or three
four four Cleveland fans that I know all
the worked at hilarious so if they're
listening you know who are you know you
know you are anyway I actually ordered
some football cards and I have those
things coming and back in the day when I
was a kid all right is everybody back in
the day if you go far enough back that
they were actually a kid at some point
right I used to just look at those
football cards over and over and over
again I couldn't get enough of him I
just found them so [ __ ] fascinating I
didn't realize that it was all seeping
into my [ __ ] brain and that by it
applied that same sort if I had that
same sort of passion towards academia
who knows where it would I would have
gone to Notre Dame I would have become a
lawyer
that's what I would have done that was
the goal but instead of studying what I
needed to study
I studied football cards so now to this
day I am a fifth almost 52 year old man
and I'm still buying old football cards
off of ebay and I'm finally unearthing
all of this [ __ ] that I have in my
office and I found all my old football
cards and my my wife doesn't know this
but I'm bringing them out of my podcast
garage area and I'm bringing them into
the house into the living room we have
like a bookcase there and I'm
just gonna have him on the bottom shelf
and that's gonna be my [ __ ] late at
night all these old football cards from
the years that I haven't before I watch
football I'm just gonna look at those
things the way I did like when I was a
kid you know what and that's gonna get
me through this [ __ ] pandemic that's
that's what I'm doing we all do what we
can try to do anyway I'm just [ __ ]
around with all the doctor nurse [ __ ]
open economy [ __ ] I'm really hoping this
is gonna work it has to work
it just has to that's it it's going to
work well we're just all gonna wear
gloves and masks and we're all gonna
[ __ ] go back to work and that's it
and they're gonna get a [ __ ] test out
to everybody and test everybody if you
[ __ ] have it stay home and the rest
of us go to [ __ ] work we go to work
and we're able to [ __ ] afford
whatever the [ __ ] it was we were doing
beforehand we have to do it and I think
what makes this country great is the
fact that when the federal government
says you have to do something after a
while the states are like well we don't
give a [ __ ] because down here in
such-and-such state we put our [ __ ]
duck hunting boots on one rubber foot at
a time I blew my leg off
all right albums that I've been
downloading I actually downloaded and I
meant to buy this on cassette tape 34
years ago I bought Cinderella Knight
songs and I'm cleaning my house the
other day right I had my mic bose
headset on right this all sounds like
I'm [ __ ] sliding advertising and
doesn't it and I was listening to that
shake me that's the song that's the hit
as far as I can tell I've been watching
reels too so I know a lot about music so
the next thing you know I got my little
ukulele out I'm figuring out how to play
it well Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Dubonnet mon - wow you always had to had
that Wadud eau de todo in every [ __ ]
metal song real power chord pal power
chord pal power chord pal power chord
and then when you buy Deva the bow it
[ __ ] worked so that's what I was
doing I was doing that last night and I
I don't know what else to [ __ ] tell
you I just this is just I mean I thought
I was gonna [ __ ] crush the podcast
game during this [ __ ] pandemic cuz I
never really [ __ ] had any guests
anyway so I'm like everybody else their
shows they're gonna suffer but nope no
I'm saying this isn't [ __ ] working
out let me get to some of the
advertising here oh god I got a prior I
have an ATC podcast promo getting better
with Ron Funches it's a podcast about
staying motivated it's basically the
exact opposite of this podcast as far as
I can tell staying motivated reaching
goals and working towards the things you
love I like to think this podcast is
also about that in a more
rough-and-tumble
sort of way angry kunti sort of way I'll
[ __ ] you something I learned about the
NFL Jesus Christ God help you if you're
not a [ __ ] NFL fan I'm doing what I
can't people I just have to disappear
down a dumb hobby alright I'm sorry this
is something I did not know did you know
from 1960 to 1969 the NFL had something
called the playoff ball the losers the
[ __ ] losers of basically the AFC in
the NFC title game whenever the [ __ ]
they called them back then would play
each other after the NFL title game in a
few years after the all-star game which
was also the Pro Bowl game so you had
like the NFL title game then you'd have
the all-star game and then the week
after that was the the game for third
place
then these guys would go out there and
play this game and it was considered an
exhibition game and none of those
[ __ ] points in stats counted and you
still had to play the game it was
considered like a promo game and I hate
to do this to Lions fans but the Lions
won the most they were they were the
team of the decade when it came to being
in third place where the [ __ ] is the
document the document documentary the
document I had it here hang on a second
let me find this [ __ ] thing I wrote
down all the winners in one year the
Packer said to play and [ __ ]
what's-his-face was less than happy
Vince Lombardi called it the [ __ ] bull
all right here we go Oh wrote it down
where the [ __ ] is it come on Jesus maybe
I didn't NFL titles by the decade oh I
just put the AFL one down all right
here's a weird thing about titles isn't
is in 48 and 49 the Eagles 158 59 the
Colts won nothing in this in this 60s in
the 70 78 79 the [ __ ] Steelers won in
88 and 89 the 49ers won
isn't that sorry all right let's get off
the subject I can feel you guys going
like Bill my [ __ ] eyes my eyes is my
eyes is Bill see my eyes are [ __ ]
glazing over here let me get back to the
Jesus don't you hate when you got too
many [ __ ] windows open come on bill
what are you doing here
I got to stop watching by the way those
[ __ ] animals killing other animals
that videos
you know this verse that
you know this verse the other [ __ ]
thing because I am when I go into the
back yard even during the day I start I
have like you know thoughts of coyotes
mountain lions and bears because they do
exist out here not really bears or my
lad is a couple of my lights I don't
[ __ ] know I just keep thinking that
like what every time I'm out in the
driveway you know ride bikes with my
daughter I just I just had my head on a
swivel you know I just I read something
where that these animals were getting a
little more bold cuz nobody was around
and they were reclaiming territory and
[ __ ] like that I I don't know maybe all
right bill just read the advertising we
really you're supposed to be a beacon of
strength I'm supposed to be one of the
heroes that you think here you know put
my sweat pants on one oversized leg at a
time I will ask again what are the
comedian's giving all right simply safe
with all the uncertainty in the world
God they just have to keep feeling safe
at home has never been more important
what what are you gonna do climbing you
safe it's why I want to talk to you
about simply safe home security their
longtime friends of the Monday morning
podcast and for good reason this is
actually some serious [ __ ] because if
they don't reopen the economy the
zombies are gonna start coming up your
front walk and you're gonna want to know
that they're coming up before they
realize that you're you know that
they're coming up and I don't think that
you need a well maybe you do if they
actually have a real gun I think you can
just get a BB gun with co2 cartridge and
just laugh your ass off watching a
zombie going out [ __ ] leap simply
safe has made it easy to finally get
comprehensive protection for your home
didn't I used to do a bit about that
there's no technician or salesperson
that needs to come and disrupt your
house you don't need to pay any
outrageous monthly fees or sign a
two-year contract you just order online
set it up yourself in under an hour and
your home is protected 24/7 with
emergency dispatch for break-ins fire
and more all for just fifty cents a day
and we're not only we're not the only
fans of simply safe oh this is for all
punk-ass I'm not the only fan of simply
safe US News and World Report named
simply safe best overall home security
of 2020
right now when you need when you head to
simply safe calm / / my listeners will
get free shipping and a 60 day risk-free
trial that simply safe calm / / - make
sure they know that our show sent you
from simply safe and all of us here
wishing you safety and good health all
right and lastly but not leastly oh look
who it is
they've been here since the beginning
stamps.com for all our sakes we need to
avoid crowds any way we can right now
how can we use this current situation to
show how viable our park is but what if
you need to go to the post office what
if you need postage to send out letters
and packages
this is classic creating a need with the
copy
that's why you need stamps calm anything
you can do with the post office you can
do it stamps.com print postage on demand
and skip those lines and crowds at the
post office plus you can actually save
money save some money with discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office you've heard me talk about stamps
calm
they've been sponsoring the show for
over seven years now and if you haven't
tried it what are you waiting for
stamps.com brings all the surfaces of
the US Postal Service right to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own home office or anywhere else
you are hunkering down right now whether
you're a small business sending invoices
and online seller shipping out products
or you're just looking to work from home
that's gonna happen a lot I think after
this pandemic is over right and need to
mail stuff stamps calm can handle it all
with ease once your mail is ready just
leave it for your mail carrier schedule
a free package pick up or drop it in a
mailbox no human contact required it's
that simple and like I said with stamps
calm you get great discounts - five
cents off every first-class stamping up
to 40% off usps shipping united states
postal service shipping rates and right
now in addition to offering discount US
Postal Service rates stamps calm also
offers UPS services with discounts up to
62 percent plus with stamps calm you
won't even have to pay UPS residential
surcharges still going is a no-brainer
especially now saving you time and money
and keeping you safe in these crazy
times right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free shipping and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur B you are our all
capital letters that stamps calm and
tuber stay safe my friends we went from
stay thirsty my friends to stay safe my
friends what do you guys think after
this [ __ ] is all over I saw a thing on
Twitter so you know it's got to be true
we're saying that they possibly found
some sort of something that stopped it
so we're gonna be all good
but my question and my question is when
we go back was zoom a fluke
was it a boy band burning across the sky
or does it actually change our business
is going to be looking going you know I
don't need office space this big alright
people can work from home people gonna
start working from home and I'll tell
you this right now if you think that'll
be great for the environment on so many
different levels there'll be less
traffic the air will be cleaner the
price of gas will go down less people
using gas the price goes down
all right less planes in the sky the sky
looks bluer people will be working from
home they will be grazing all day they
will gain weight they will drop dead
they will be here in their houses four
days before anybody realizes they
haven't checked in at work their cats
will do what they have to do and start
feeI sorry I'm wondering that's if
that's gonna happen because I'm really
hoping that with like all things comedy
that we can handle a lot of our meetings
our pitch meetings and all of that via
zoom and be three four less jackasses
driving across LA to go pitch a [ __ ]
show I'm really hoping that that's gonna
happen and I hope that a lot of these
business trips that people will just use
video conferencing and save a ton of
[ __ ] money I know this is gonna be
bad for the airlines
but uh you know we got to do something
here man I'm [ __ ] watching jeopardy
the other night and then one of the
answers was some sort of [ __ ]
glaciers and then they like go see them
now before they melt you know just
giving we're just giving in that we're
gonna [ __ ] up the planet come on man
let's all stay in our houses and eat
ourselves to death which I know right
now is not a fun thing because you can't
really go outside without your mask kiss
kiss kiss kiss and your gloves on but
once you know once everything's opened
up due to the courage of Texas Georgia
and Orange County California and Omaha
Nebraska the heroes they're gonna go out
and brave possibly coming home and
sneezing on an older person and killing
them just to get a slice of cheesecake
at the Cheesecake Factory these heroes
these people well he died doing what he
wanted to do going to Steak and Shake
and getting a black-and-white shake he
died doing what he loved
you know going to Sonic burger having
somebody rollerskate up to his [ __ ]
Ford Pinto that's when you died too soon
and everybody thinks you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right you died doing what you
loved he died doing what he loved taking
a selfie hanging off a [ __ ] radio
tower alright that is the podcast
everybody let's all let's all get
together in in in in hold hands
fiber optically how do you say this uh
virally and bow our heads go Joel
Olsteen here and say a prayer for
everybody in Orange County Texas Omaha
Nebraska in Georgia Jesus Jesus in your
infinite wisdom and your long flowing
robe if you could just keep strength to
the people out there let them if they're
gonna get sneezed now and let them dodge
them covet particles and let them get
their Oreo cookie slice of cheesecake
down there at the mall keep them safe
and in your minds and in your thoughts
and in your prayers this week ladies and
gentlemen let's just hope we could
reopen the economy and get back out
there
all the while actually most of us still
working from home so the glaciers don't
melt god bless you god bless the United
States of America god bless all people
but specifically the people here in this
country because that's where I live all
right have a great weekend enjoy the
music and the bonus Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcasts that will come in right after
the music selected by the great Andrew
stemless hey what's going on it's Bill
burr and it's the Monday morning podcast
for Monday April 30th I just slammed the
[ __ ] mixer now everything's too quiet
hello hello hello my baby hello my honey
where the [ __ ] have you been you [ __ ]
who
[Music]
um what's up how are you I'm back from
I'm back from the east coast back from
the east coast I did a wonderful gig at
the University of Concord in Concord New
Hampshire I had an awesome time I want
to thank everybody who came out I had a
great time and I don't know what to tell
you it's been a while since I did a
college gig it was actually cool because
it was it was open to the public
usually when they have college gigs they
they're not open to the public in case
you were wondering case you didn't
understand when I said usually they're
not open to the public the first time or
whatever the [ __ ] I said I don't know
what I just said
usually it's just it's just all gonna be
students students and then a couple of
crabby teachers hanging in the
background or maybe some rat of a
student who's gonna sit there and wait
for you to say something you know and
then write about it and blog about it
and the next thing you know you're on
good merry Good Morning America Good
Morning America right who pitched that
[ __ ] show I mean God knows it's a hit
but Jesus Christ how did how did you
pitch that name of for a show without
either without like either snickering as
you said the name of the show or having
your balls pull up inside of you I want
to do a show nationally syndicated and
it it starts at 6:00 in the morning and
it's called Good Morning America good
why would you do that and we I just want
to sit there and be pleasant for three
hours you know I took a meeting with
somebody the other day yes I just said
that that's how Hollywood I am I took a
meeting and by taking a meeting I mean I
went out and I got a [ __ ] omelet sat
across from somebody say I'd like
[ __ ] toast between the tifa's and
better I don't think I don't think it's
ever gonna happen for me people I think
I'm gonna be like Willie Nelson I think
I'm gonna be on the road my whole life
man cuz I got to tell you got to tell
you what I
that freedom in my bones man I [ __ ] up
you know I mean I [ __ ] up in my career
how did you [ __ ] up bill I stayed out
there too long you know like that 43
year old guy still in the clubs sucking
in his gut with the button-down shiny
shirt still hittin on the lay right
teeth are already starting to discolor
you know cuz you're so old no matter how
much you brush them they still just
after a while you just can't keep up
with the red wine tied it just keeps
your teeth just a little grayer and I
stayed out on the road too long I did I
was a stand-up comic for too long I
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] up and now I don't
know how to work with other people
because for 20 years it's been hey
here's an idea and then I go yeah I
agree with that you know why cuz it's my
idea I totally agree with that [ __ ] and
now now all the sudden I'm coming in
from from the [ __ ] bush right after
20 goddamn tours and now I got a sit
here and try and work with other people
I don't know how to do it I really
shouldn't be saying this in my podcast I
don't know how to [ __ ] do it
you know we saw your tape we really
liked it
we thought that you were we have really
mainstream sort of comedy yeah I really
don't think it's mainstream I say [ __ ]
every other word yeah I know but but
there's the mainstream sensibility to it
and I'm literally sitting there going
alright this is an argument and [ __ ]
six weeks right I don't know I'm you
know what I'm talking about what the
[ __ ] was that going with that oh let's
let's rewind we weren't we weren't New
Hampshire beautiful goddamn state by the
way and the people aren't as simple as
they try to make them every year every
four years you know when there's a
presidential election and you do that
little quaint piece about the primary
Zoey started having steak called New
Hampshire Heather
down-to-earth kind of [ __ ] people
whenever they say salt of the earth down
to earth that's their that's their
euphemism for calling you [ __ ] you
know what I mean there really is sort of
a media bias where if you don't live in
New York or LA you're just considered a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know what I mean all those goddamn
shows you dis you just a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
that goddamn TV shows you know there's
always the smart person who moved from
New York or some major city back to
their hometown and everybody there is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] right but I don't know
maybe there's some [ __ ] truth to it
who the hell know so anyways I'm up in
Concord New Hampshire beautiful state
lush state plenty of trees plenty of
water plenty of game and fish you know
plenty of fatties right there food
source they were already mama maybe
think about that when you look what you
think about yourself is like what kind
of shape you're in like if someone was
to throw you on a grill like what kind
of steak would you be you know would you
be a lean cut of meat you know make a
filet mignon or would you be a [ __ ]
New York Strip a goddamn ribeye one of
those John Candy steaks I gotta tell you
I've been on the [ __ ] road a little
bit uh now you notice I take my special
and then I was just like well [ __ ] it I
can get fat again
cuz I don't got to worry about being on
TV for another two years so we started
eating Sunday's what up study I just
started having lunches like you did when
you were in the seventh grade you know
there's like a bag of Fritos and a soda
and some sort of some sort of protein
was somehow in there right some bread
anyways I'm trying to dance around this
[ __ ] subject but uh the Bruins lost
Bruins lost there's nothing like there's
nothing like I don't know losing in
overtime sucks but I don't know what it
is about hockey hockey it's just so
[ __ ] it just it killed you right so
we lose but I gotta be honest with you
capitals were definitely a better team I
felt they were they were the better team
pretty much every game this guy Kevin
DuPont for the Boston Globe wrote a
great article where he just basically
summed up the series where they just
were always a little better a little
her had a little better defense a little
bit of for checking just a little better
everything so they deserve it [ __ ]
pricks so then what happens right the
overtime goal for people aren't hockey
fans was scored by a guy who was not
white he was not Asian I was a black guy
scored the goal right so then like you
know it's a game seven it's in Boston
Boston loses so right then you know
what's gonna happen all the [ __ ]
races come out of the woodwork they text
like goddamn a hundred of those things
just calling the guy the n-word like
you're talking like like [ __ ] that they
would cut out of the script and like
Mississippi Burning going like all right
you know what that's too [ __ ] harsh
so I start getting all these emails
going through what's up with all the
racist Boston fans and blah blah blah
trashing me and I'm like I was in this
hilarious you know this is hilarious you
so basically you're not supposed to
judge all by a few but it's okay to do
it in this direction so I'm on my
[ __ ] high horse right so I go back to
Boston just so happens this weekend and
I'm hanging out one off in Boston and I
hate to admit it I heard the n-word
twice I heard it alluded to another time
and I just finally had that I had to
[ __ ] go home you know I'm not saying
it's worse than Alabama but I don't
think it's any better it's [ __ ]
brutal
granted I did go to a [ __ ] bar it was
the gene pool I was in but I you know I
can't defend it I can't defend it
anymore it's [ __ ] embarrassing
I don't know it's [ __ ] embarrassing
Good Morning America
how are you alright let's get on with
the [ __ ] and unbelievably ignorant
too you know I just [ __ ] I I just I'd
for the life of me
I don't get it one of the guys had a
lazy eye - that's what killed me you
know it's like dude have you looked in
two mirrors simultaneously and seen what
you're looking at how the [ __ ] are you
looking down on anybody now now let's so
now I got two trash people lazy eyes to
get my point across that I don't
appreciate racist people I'm a [ __ ]
idiot myself but you know what I'm gonna
I'm doing something about it unlike
those morons I ran to back in my [ __ ]
embarrassing city over the weekend
I'm sick of not having a good science
background so I actually went to a
bookstore one of the few remaining
bookstores out there and I bought a book
on how to rebuild a carburetor and I
also bought a book on the elements it's
hilarious it's this big giant book and
my mind is already blown because this
[ __ ] is like magic to me
telling me that that my foot that
everything's made out of matter what the
[ __ ] did it say the earth this book your
foot everything is tangible everything
tangible is made of elements your foot
is made mostly of oxygen with quite a
bit of carbon joining it giving its
structure to the organic molecules that
define you as an example of carbon-based
life I was like that just [ __ ] blew
my mind I don't know is carbon in me
carbon fiber I don't know what carbon
fiber what do they do is it nothing like
getting in bulletproof vests this out
dummy it I have no idea so then I'm
sitting there going so does that mean
you can kind of shoot me in the foot you
know with some sort of low caliber gun
and it's gonna wreck ashay off or if it
goes through does all the air come out I
just don't get it I don't [ __ ] get it
alright I've gone on these [ __ ]
websites I try and read about how a
plane flies I swear to God Wikipedia
it's hilarious like you know when you're
reading about trying to figure out how
to a goddamn plane flies they have you
know they'll have whatever they live
like you know two pages on the [ __ ]
basically explaining house it goes down
and like every paragraph has like two
words highlighted in case you don't know
what that means and I have to click on
every word so click on a word and then
they start to define that and then it's
the same thing it's another page of [ __ ]
wherever your paragraph there's three
more things highlighted and then I got
to click on that thing and I just keep
getting further and further away from
how the [ __ ] plane flies and I get
all the way down to like page 1 of
Wikipedia it's goddamn like you know
scratch and sniff picture with some lady
with like a sock puppet trying to
explain let's just let's just start
really really slow I'm sick of it all
right I think there's something I don't
know what's going on with my truck it
hesitates in first gear first gear so I
thought it was a clutch someone else
says it could be the clutch or it could
be in your cabaret so I start reading up
on carburetors right and whole [ __ ]
the whole philosophy create a vacuum and
and in whatever that word is when you
turn a liquid into a goddamn mist and at
the end of it I'm just looking at this
think oh this is just a bunch of [ __ ]
screws and springs you know why don't he
just go into the junkyard get one take
it apart and put it back together and
just keep reading these [ __ ] books
and eventually at some point it has to
click right so that's what I'm doing I
went on eBay cuz I'm too [ __ ] lazy
because I'm a [ __ ] Hollywood phony
rather than go down to a salvage yard
you know I'm gonna [ __ ] just go on
eBay and bid on some old carburetor
there's gonna be a fight when that thing
shows up it's gonna be a little box and
he's gonna see it think I bought her
something nice oh it has a lot of weight
to it it's got to be expensive I wonder
if it's shiny and then she's gonna open
it up there's gonna be some old [ __ ]
good old ass carburetor you know I don't
know kiddy guys at least give me points
for trying does that work how about Paul
virzi last week everybody who became a
father again today congratulations to
New Jersey's own Paul virzi and a
beautiful baby girl
today how about how much did he kill it
last week you know people be the most
people 90 percent of people loved him
and then those people who weren't into
sports and they thought it was like the
worst podcast ever I had some [ __ ]
douchebags from across the way I don't
know where he was over in Europe or
something and he goes why don't you just
call your podcast a sports podcast just
so you know you're losing all of your
floor and listeners right like he speaks
for all a [ __ ] Swahili I hate when
people do that [ __ ] it was one [ __ ]
goddamn podcast
alright you selfish [ __ ]
how [ __ ] unfunny are the people in
your country that you have to go all the
way across the Atlantic Ocean to find a
podcast to listen to you jackass let me
tell you something a person from another
country don't [ __ ] threaten me
alright you [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if
you listen to this and not I really
don't so don't send me [ __ ] Twitter
messages like it like I'm sitting here
shakin all right I don't need you to
continue to make no money you ever
thought about that
[ __ ] sitting here buy and use goddamn
carburetors I'm gonna sit there and
threaten me like you're taking something
away from me go [ __ ] yourself with your
wooden shoes huh what do you live in
Greece or something you mad at me cuz
your [ __ ] economy what the hell is
going on over there understand how that
whole thing collapsed everybody rioted
and but still everybody's still fine you
know people are eating they're not happy
but you know they're out there you have
an a Greek salad do they call it a Greek
salad over there just say let me get a
salad you know or like like that's like
in in Philly they go let me get a
cheesesteak they don't go let me get a
Philly let me get a Philadelphia
cheesesteak let me get a steak them on a
stale bun with [ __ ] Cheez Whiz Jesus
Christ no other people so fat and ugly
in that goddamn city huh
they won the other day right
Philadelphia's a big wind Danny Briere
the only time I ever seen a guy scored
two goals in one overtime you did the
impossible first time he did it he was a
cheetah you know there was a kicking
motion I was in a bar actually drinking
when that happened listening to people
say racist things to me dude it's bad
enough that they lost but then the guy
who scored it was and I was like what do
you when I was [ __ ] racists on Twitter
oh no I'm just you know I'm just saying
I like when people do they'd they [ __ ]
backtrack the ignorance of what people
were saying to me yeah dude you hear
about so-and-so yeah I got two [ __ ]
kids and then his wife went gay I swear
to God
direct quote his wife went gay yeah
she's [ __ ] abroad now [ __ ] sucks
kid went gay you know like like you I
went to the store then I went to the
post office and then I went gay that's
that's what happens there's a little
busy store down there's a little
homosexuality store that you can go to
[ __ ] jaw-droppingly stupid not saying
everybody the irony is that Harvard is
there that's the funny thing at MIT and
all that you know so the Boston has this
weird [ __ ] sort of like you know a
couple people who are really smart and
then the rest of us it's it is Good Will
Hunting except we're not good at math
[Laughter]
that stupid [ __ ] movie Jesus Christ
he's a genius at math and he goes around
beating the [ __ ] out of people when was
the last time a mathlete went around
bullying people you know and then what
an accountant who can do 30 pull-ups
what what else what I mean how much of a
[ __ ] leap am I supposed to make in
these goddamn movies you know what line
I hate the most in Good Will Hunting I
know I brought this up before is when
[ __ ]
they're in the therapy session and you
know he's got the hammer the wrench and
I said I took the [ __ ] wrench cuz you
know [ __ ] him right or whatever the
[ __ ] line is and then they asked he
asked Robin Williams what he's been
shinned and he says 260 there's no way
that was written in the script how much
power does Robin Williams have that the
director won't be like hey Robin can you
drop that number down a little bit so
this movie can stay remotely believable
to 60 what after you add up benching 70
pounds 10 times weight 70 pounds 10
anyways plowing ahead this is the Monday
morning podcast by the way and a lot of
you have been well you've been giving me
[ __ ] by the way cuz lately they haven't
been coming out I have a phenomenal
[ __ ] excuse that you're gonna
understand in about 10 months as to why
I was late alright you [ __ ] why do you
call it the Monday morning podcast
because I record them on Monday mornings
except when I'm busy and I love for the
most part I get the [ __ ] thing out
you know right right now it's 10:30
Monday morning my time when I'm doing
this [ __ ] thing so it is the Monday
morning podcast in my [ __ ] world can
you stop making it about yourself and
then every once in a while once in a
[ __ ] blue moon I'm so busy I can't
get it done until a Tuesday and all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] come out of the
woodwork once you go [ __ ] slap your
mom why don't you do that a couple of
times
forehand backhand forehand and then just
[ __ ] give it one of those little nose
twisties but being dumb enough to not be
on birth control alright
advertising advice hey Bill instead of
telling people to go to your podcast
page and click on the Amazon link tell
them to go to your podcast page clear
the cookies on their browser then click
the amazon.com link as soon as they get
there add the page to their bookmarks
then every time they visit amazon.com
from the bookmarks their bookmarks it's
the same as clicking the link on your
page without actually having to go
there it's the [ __ ] future man that's
what he wrote um yeah if my listeners
are smart enough to do that I don't know
how do you clear the cookies how do you
do that I don't know how to do it I
bought a new laptop by the way everybody
and it's the most annoying thing ever is
now I don't know how to do anything you
know I can't [ __ ] do anything anymore
I I wanna I can't even figure out how to
[ __ ] put a photo up to make it my
screensaver I don't know how to do it
now because now it's completely [ __ ]
different on the new MacBook Pro you
know I don't understand these [ __ ]
computers it's like you know I go out
and I buy a car yeah it's a little
faster technology little but I still
know how to drive it gas brake put it in
Drive you know this not these [ __ ]
[ __ ] not all [ __ ] no belt Magoo
they're whatever the [ __ ] his name is
the guy with the New Balance who finally
died thank God that douchebag are we
switching everything up never having the
Chargers fit the old phone all this [ __ ]
going into the ocean you know I love how
that guy like used to compare themselves
to Gandhi a did Gandhi did he have like
a sweatshop of people jumping to their
deaths cuz they were making Gandhi
[ __ ] iPads like I had a lot of balls
man you know he really did with this
turtleneck and his salt-and-pepper pubes
I really didn't like been a pothead for
ten years here we go here we go twenty
minutes in been a pothead for ten years
hey Bill I'm a comedy junkie among other
things and I really appreciate your show
well thank you very much it helps me get
through my commute but apathy and the
awkwardness of working in a law firm and
I just want to say I appreciate your
show it's really a release for me
why is it awkward working in a law firm
has that word awkward just kind of lost
all meaning is that like the default
adjective everybody goes everybody goes
to now hey ran into your girlfriend the
other night in the bar awkward why was
it awkward it's a bar was what what
happened in there that was awkward
you work in a law firm why is that
awkward
that sounds like a very good job why am
i speaking like a robot um anyways but
anyway I've smoked weed on and off
taking year breaks here and there since
about 2001 when I was in high school
however when I did smoke I smoked every
day multiple times a day it really
didn't affect me much until recently
about eight years of this after about
eight years of this when I turned 25 I
started to notice some slowness
physically mentally and just in
everything I did I hated it but I didn't
want to stop smoking I could very well
stop easily but I'd always feel like I'd
be happy or high I remember you talking
about some guy you knew who freaked out
when he found out he couldn't smoke when
you took him on a road trip that is a
little extreme to me and I am nowhere
near that type of personality I'm now 26
and I'm slowly slowing down quite a bit
to just once a night if at all we can
also get expensive the more you smoke
I think smoking is okay but if you
haven't then I would because it's sort
of like beer where it starts off as
nothing and ends up as a crutch anyways
I just feel like if you smoke that's
fine but be organized about it to make
sure it's not affecting your personality
or other types of interaction or
whatever honestly I wish I never smoked
in my life because it's so hard to look
at someone smoking it and not want to
ask for a toke if anyone who smokes weed
wants some advice mine would be moved to
California get a card smoke your how to
heart out and find out how positive /
negative it really is at least this way
you're doing it legally I know because I
I know this because I did it not for the
weed more for a girlfriend but I digress
and if anyone cares Girl Scout cookies
are the [ __ ] by the way if you thought I
was white I'm not I'm Chinese all right
I think it was a little high when he
wrote that that last paragraph he's by
the end of it he's just [ __ ] he's
eatin cookies
getting paranoid they think I'm white
man yeah I think well I think weed is
it's just like I think in a lot of ways
it's like booze
in that you know you have a beer here
you have a beer there it's not a big
deal but if yeah it starts consuming
your life I mean that's a major
statement like you know I could not
smoke weed but I just feel I would be
happier if I did for some reason with
weed people don't really see that as
that's like a major red flag it's just
not considered that's actually
considered funny and like logical but
like if I said you know I don't have to
drink but I just feel like my life is
happier when I do or I'd be happier if I
was drunk you know what I mean or people
will get like hi before they go in to go
to work and they're kind of like hi for
the first couple hours like that would
be like me shotgunning a couple of beers
in the parking lot I mean just picture
that you know he walking by and you see
a boss you catch a mid like you know
he's looking out of his peripheral is he
sucking on the side of a bud tall you
know I don't know I think it's
definitely like anything it can't be
good to sit there putting all that
[ __ ] smoke in your lungs the same way
I don't know I think the danger about
alcohol is when you're [ __ ] up your
liver I don't think you really notice
until it's [ __ ] up whereas like I
think if you smoke a lot you kind of oh
my god I'm really winded this has really
affected me I think like your liver is
the only recently I started learning
about how bad booze I mean you always
say that cirrhosis of the liver but I
mean I thought you literally had to be
walking around with a glass in your hand
all the time and I know a number of guys
who are you know dealing with that [ __ ]
now and uh lemon put lemon in your water
clears out you [ __ ] liver so what was
what was actually your point here been a
pothead for ten years you just share in
your experience as you rolled up another
one and got super paranoid
alright cheating [ __ ] is a great story
bill I want to thank you for helping me
out with a really hard time in my life
um I'm 24 years old a student at a
university and I had a girlfriend could
this was font to be any [ __ ] smaller
uh and I had a girlfriend two years
younger than me we were going out for
seven months she's working at a local
cafe
and about three weeks ago out of the
[ __ ] blue comes to me and tells me
that a regular at the cafe was hitting
on it she told me that she had a boy she
told him that she had a boyfriend and
was reassuring to me that nothing was
going on but we had some problems in our
relationship that we needed to fix
because she felt good with all the
flirting and she didn't want to cheat on
me wait a minute but we had some
problems in a relationship that we
needed to fix because she felt good with
all the flirting and she didn't want to
cheat on me also she liked this guy
hitting on him Jesus anyways he says I
took that [ __ ] hard and I told her I
would do anything do anything to make
her happy even though she knew I loved
her so I did I gave her all my time and
energy to make her happy ah there you go
there's a [ __ ] recipe from misery
[ __ ] all my dreams let me sit here and
cater to your emotions you [ __ ]
that was the cliff notes um anyways then
one week ago she calls me and breaks up
with me tells me that she [ __ ] with
that guy because she was developing
strong feelings for me and was scared
that I would hurt her you gotta give it
up to him you gotta give it up women are
like there a guy has to learn how to be
a pimp women just naturally know how to
do it and I swear to god it all comes
down to the fact that they can't beat
the [ __ ] out of us the fact that we
could beat the living [ __ ] out of a
woman is what kills us in an argument
because you're taking solace in
something that you're never gonna do you
know it's this card you're never gonna
play hopefully unless you're a [ __ ]
animal meanwhile they're developing
themselves mentally and figuring out how
you work psychologically and they're
just like I'd really think once you're
on sharing a relationship just to make
it fair to help the guy I think like
three days a week or at least during the
arguments like the second the argument
starts the woman should always have on
like tearaway clothes and she pulls him
off and then she's immediately dressed
like Hannibal Lecter you know that
ice-cream man outfit that he had you
know has her hair slicked back so you
just really know what you're [ __ ]
with
that is brilliant can you imagine trying
to say that to your girl listen I [ __ ]
this hottie at work but it's only
because I care about you so much and I
was worried that you were gonna hurt me
because my love for you is so deep
Jesus you know what I think I would
high-five her I'd high-five Ron knock a
couple of her [ __ ] press-on nails off
that was a good one
so anyways he goes I know it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] I lost my mind I went to the
cafe and I beat the [ __ ] out of that guy
Wow
mainly because if I didn't I was gonna
beat her and she didn't deserve to find
any excuse what mainly because if I
didn't I was gonna beat her and she
didn't deserve to find any excuse and
because he was an a-hole for hitting on
a girl who was in a relationship yeah
dude I don't know about that I don't
know about that he's doing what a guy
does a guy goes around and tries to [ __ ]
women okay he's not in a relationship
with her and he's certainly not in a
relationship with you
the person who is wrong in that is the
woman you know now if that guy knows you
or you came down you gave him a warning
you know came down with your Clint
Eastwood eyes all squinted up stay away
from her you know you did one of those
and then he didn't then that's on him
but you just come out of nowhere can you
please elaborate on that like what was
he doing was he down at the restaurant
like you know making a [ __ ] egg over
easy and all of a sudden you came did
you beat him down the street like
[ __ ] a Sonny and the Godfather didn't
even get thrown into some like trash
blue trashcan lid or something like that
like one of those [ __ ] the whole
whole goddamn [ __ ] neighborhood sees
it um I actually respect it in a way but
you shouldn't do it because then you get
sued and then she actually feels like
she's right see I knew you was crazy
now the [ __ ] is blaming me for making a
scene oh there it is and because her
boss her bosses look at her and think
she is a [ __ ] if she if she didn't
if she didn't thought about the if she
didn't think about the consequences why
should I
what was I in the wrong I don't want to
regret what I did because she deserved
it all I did was love her and she slept
with another guy [ __ ] hurts man it
really does I can't move on thank you
for hearing me out
all right you know what when I said you
shouldn't have beat that beat the guy up
that what that was for you that had
nothing to do with her I just don't want
you to get sued or go to jail or uh you
know you know you get a [ __ ] record I
mean dude you're you're you made a move
there that could alter your future
and believe me dude there's a great
thing about [ __ ] is when you really
there's a man this is gonna hurt like
hell but there's gonna be a moment where
you're gonna find this [ __ ] hilarious
you really if you got to believe me on
this one at some point you're gonna be
talking about it out loud to your
friends and you're just gonna say this
situation out loud that you were in and
there'll be enough time has gone by that
your feelings for this girl have faded
and it's almost like it's somebody else
and you're gonna laugh at yourself and
then you're gonna laugh at the whole
[ __ ] thing and it's probably gonna
hit you that was that why did I risk
going to jail maybe you know I don't
have like a felony or something like
that on your record like though this
isn't the mother your kids alright you
can't trust this girl as far as you can
[ __ ] throw her you know you can't as
far as you could [ __ ] pick her up by
the back of her [ __ ] g-string and the
scruff of that awful tattoo on the back
of her net that she if she doesn't have
it she's gonna get at some point and you
can't trust her you can't trust her so
you just got to get through the [ __ ]
and you're gonna be fine but in the
future dude I would not go I mean you
just basically you like the transporter
for real you just you did you did like
the movie version of what everybody
wants to do in that situation but you
did it for real and you somehow got away
with it
did you split your [ __ ] slacks when
you threw that high kick to his [ __ ]
cheekbone I just read that reason I read
an article about that guy is Jason
Statham how he has to have special pants
on because he can kick his legs so
[ __ ] high you can't do that in a suit
without it ripping now if I was
directing the movie I would be like dude
that's gonna make this [ __ ] movie so
much better that if you're standing
there in some Anderson little suit and
you're kicking so much ass your slacks a
literally disintegrating off your
[ __ ] legs how funny would that be
then he's standing there in the end he's
[ __ ] his slacks are looking like you
know the Hulk's pants right bill Bixby's
pants after he turns into the Hulk
though that's that that would be the
funniest [ __ ] thing ever
nobody would be all like the inseam in
the crotch
but like down by the bottom off I would
totally have it I'd be like dude we got
to do this with real slacks and you have
to wear knee-high black socks with
[ __ ] sock garters just we'll just do
one like this Jason can we just do one
like this yeah dude you you did that you
went the real deal on this so luckily
you got away with it and I think it's
great that everybody knows that she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and dude just affect it look she [ __ ]
around and immediately tried to put the
guilt on you then you went down there
and beat the [ __ ] out of that guy
because she's a [ __ ] and now she's
coming back at you once again blaming
you so this this was would have been the
the the cycle that she would you would
have had if you decided to share your
life with this person they would
constantly be hurting you and then
blaming you saying that you were the
reason and I sweating on you what's
[ __ ] awful there's guys out there in
relationships like that just allowing
these women to do [ __ ] like this you
know but it's never talked about on TV
because it's considered misogynistic
because it's not every woman doing it
it's not every woman that's just elect
few ya know so are the guys who beat the
[ __ ] out of women those are a select few
doesn't stop you from talking about it
nor should it
all right they're hypothetical talk-show
hosts that I'm sitting across from
alright let's do some advertising
everybody hey are you ready are you
ready for some advertising sit on down
everybody get out of [ __ ] pencil what
the hell is it I'm the goddamn worst I
had this whole [ __ ] thing set up
there it is all right hey everybody
stamps calm I think you got this one
memorized at this point but I got to
tell you I have new listeners every week
you know last week I was in my podcast
actually was quoted and said a [ __ ]
ant what the [ __ ] is that I do I want to
learn more about insects now do I kill
this one and then that means I have more
insects because this thing is eating the
other ones it's like a miniature ladybug
lady you know last week my podcast was
actually quoted and featured in Star
magazine so there you go alright so I
know I have some new listeners alright
so here's the advertising once again
from the wonderful people at stamps calm
everybody hold on to your hats they're
about ready to make your life a whole
lot easier um what do we got here stamps
comments it's so easy and so convenient
you can print official US postage using
your own computer and printer I know
that because I do that this is how I
send out all my DVDs everybody every
damn weekend when I'm gonna go out the
week before I got my DVDs I put on my
little little visor I got my little
scale
bing-bang-boom I can do it whenever I
want 24/7 whenever I want to there's no
more going oh damn it I should have gone
to the post office the post office is
always open because it's in your
apartment um anyways this is the deal
right now you go to stamps com they have
a special offer from my listeners my
followers my cult use my last name bur
be you are are for a no risk trial plus
$110 bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to fifty five dollars in
free postage
all right can't be can't loose don't
wait go to stamps calm before you do
anything else I don't care if your
baby's crying click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Burpee URR that stamps
stamps comm enter ber and you know you
don't have to go to the post office
anymore for the rest of your life you
can cut that out you know when you
finally have a day off from work right
you get it you don't have to go anymore
it's phenomenal I'm waiting for DMV calm
that's what I'm waiting for
I know they have a website I can't
figure it out alright which once again
shows you how awesome stamps calm is
because I could actually figure it out
and I'm a [ __ ] there you go
alright friends [ __ ] problem cheating
horror friends a lot of horse stuff this
week you know if I was into the stairs
the lovely Nia everybody where you going
are you gonna go work out alright I'll
see you later bringing the dog down
what's up puppy what's up puppy Oh
Bojangles you know what's great about a
pit bulls you can really throw him
around you know that's right I was
hanging at a friend's house and he had
this little cute little dog and I swear
to god this thing must have weighed like
like two pounds I was like afraid to
touch it after messing with this thing
my dogs made out of titanium dude you
smell you need a bath you know hey
codependent why don't you go lay down
over there alright and don't step on my
book about the elements
Cleo lay down lay down why do they
always gotta walk around for like 20
seconds in a circle before they figure
out how they're gonna lie down
what's the deal friends [ __ ] problem
mr. burr I love the podcast and would
really appreciate some advice regarding
my best friend and me okay
let's try and guess what this is going
either your best friend is dating a
[ __ ] or your best friend is a [ __ ]
your best friend is a [ __ ] why wouldn't
you want to [ __ ] her why don't I just
read it alright let me start with some
background information my best friend
and I have known each other since I can
remember
but recently
I'm almost at the point of losing
contact with him because he acts like a
[ __ ] idiot over some douchebag girl
he's never been a ladies man so he's
been on and off with this one just one
[ __ ] for quite a while
oh yeah he's hanging on to it he's
hanging on to it that's what he's doing
yep he's afraid another one it's not
going to come along and he's clinging to
that that one piece like that uh like
Leonardo at the end of Titanic um and
he's gonna have the same fate and this
girl always used to have a boyfriend
always has to have a boyfriend cheats on
them all the time not exaggerating
high-school dropout and she loves any
drama she can get Jesus Christ she loves
any drama she can get her grimy [ __ ]
covered hands on I hate this [ __ ]
very much in case we didn't understand
that with who the first six sentences
there are not enough adjectives in the
dictionary or synonyms in the [ __ ]
four Thoris to describe this piece of
[ __ ] so now to the story a couple of
months ago she dumped her boyfriend and
a day later started dating my best
friend nobody in our group of friends
liked her and she always acted like she
was miserable while dating my friend
weeks after them dating the old
cumdumpster is pregnant Oh get a
paternity test immediately get one of
them little swab e swabs uh he came
anyways he came inside all right dude
Jesus we get it all right he based let
me let me try and clean this up he had
unprotected sex with their to completion
because she told him it's almost
impossible for her to get pregnant my
friend is an idiot for falling for that
so instantly he jumped into marrying
this girl at the age of 19 and dating
only three or four weeks what the [ __ ]
she went to the doctor and they told her
she had been pregnant almost two weeks
prior to him busting inside her and how
she and how she acted
she knew this know how she was acting
she knew this the whole time
also the boyfriend before my friend
busted inside our many tiny ously so lo
and behold this [ __ ] runs to her ex
because he's the dad so she got the
drama she wanted now well that's good
then
so this kids not getting stuck with the
kid now several months later my friend
is back to talking to this girl and this
is where I'm pissed off beyond belief
he still somehow likes this girl that
played him acted like a complete [ __ ]
while dating him and cheated on him
while dating he thinks the kid might be
his and also said if it is his he would
get back together with her so the advice
I'm asking is so the advice dude you
guys come on man do a little proofread
here so the the advice I'm asking for is
how do I tell my friend to quit talking
to this pathetic human being and quit
being a douche about thinking about that
baby might be his when obviously it's
not and move on with his life because
that girl will never be happy and never
stop being a [ __ ] I've tried to tell him
to not talk to her and if she wants a
paternity test when it's born to take
care of the whole thing but I don't need
to read them rest of this thanks mr.
burr I really appreciate your voice on
how to get him stop being a douche ah
you can't help him you can't help this
kid I mean these aren't little drama
moments this is the biggest drama you
could possibly have at 19 when it comes
to dating alright and you would think
that after he went through the oh my god
she's pregnant and then found out it was
somebody else's that he wouldn't keep
coming back this dude has major [ __ ]
problems he needs to go see a therapist
it's not on you alright it's not on you
what are you gonna do you're gonna jump
in the car with him and try and grab the
wheel from him as he pulls back and
takes you over the cliff with them [ __ ]
it it's not your problem it's the
Goodfellas moment he's content to be a
jerk
let him be a jerk it's out of your hands
you know and if you don't want to look
at it I would just stop hanging out with
him what are you supposed to do what do
you suppose everybody you know something
I hate to say this for the most part
everybody has one guy like that in their
crew there's always one guy who's gonna
marry the [ __ ]
and find out 15 years later that it's
not his kid and you know and there's
gonna be one one person in your crew
that's gonna try and tell him that and
the kid's gonna flip out and not talk to
him at all and then 15 years later
they'll run into each other in a bar and
be like yeah you will kind of let you
kind of write so what are you gonna do
for me what the [ __ ] more does this kid
need he's an idiot
that kid is an idiot you know so he
might as well marry an idiot cuz that
cancels both of them out and it saves a
decent human being on both sides you
know uh yeah I don't want to tell you
he's just psyched if anybody will [ __ ]
him regardless of the situation and
she's a horse so she knows you know you
know she's [ __ ] his brains out so I
really don't anything funny to say about
that that's just that's [ __ ] awful
it's gotta suck for you cuz that's your
friend but uh you know you're gonna lose
some friends in life I gotta tell you
this is there's a number of different
ways you lose friends in life you know
the awful ways they die or you [ __ ]
around with their women or they [ __ ]
around with your women there's the
you're dating someone who's doing [ __ ]
like this person and then there's the
other ones where you know you start
doing well in life and they're not and
then they resent you oh the other way
around
maybe you're the resentful [ __ ] but
you're gonna lose some friends so you
lost one because you're not gonna be
able to hang out with this kid anymore I
don't know just I don't know what to
tell you dude you [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is
his dad where's his mom where are the
people like advising this kid
Jesus Christ I would [ __ ] lock that
kid up in the the room room above the
garage like a heroin addict and I just
keep giving him chicken noodle soup
until he got over this [ __ ] chick I
don't know
Jesus I hope this one's [ __ ] up
beaten shitty uncle um shitty uncle hey
Bill
I'm a lady listener and before I jump
into it here I just want to say that as
a female listener I don't have a problem
with any of your women trashing hey nice
to see someone has a sense of humor
I think the only women that get offended
or insulted by what you talk about are
the ones who can relate to or feel they
reflect in some way what you're talking
about sometimes and then sometimes I am
a [ __ ] but I appreciate you actually
seeing that anyways maybe you're talking
about the gold-digging [ __ ] or just
overall annoyance of women clearly
that's not all women but ones who send
you shitty emails feel like you're
speaking of them because they are like
that [ __ ] them [ __ ] them I think it's
hilarious
absolutely ridiculous when one listener
out a thousand takes one thing you talk
about tries to make it personal what a
bunch of [ __ ] you know what this
weekend when I did my show and I closed
with my gold-digging [ __ ] but I was
selling DVDs afterward you know whoring
myself out showing a little bit of leg
as I do and this couple came up and the
woman paid and some other woman yelled
yelled as she walked by yeah and I used
to take the bait on that and I just left
I just left and it warmed my heart
knowing that I annoyed the [ __ ] out of
her
with my closing 10 minute gold-digging
[ __ ] bit so anyways here we go
so here's the family problem I'd
appreciate your perspective on I've got
this absolute absolute [ __ ] of an
uncle
he's a recovered alcoholic who's landed
himself a wife with money oh Jesus the
guy's been a con man since I can
remember it's just that now he's a sober
con man yeah I really don't like addicts
generally speaking generally speaking
that some of the most selfish
[ __ ] on the planet and they do
some of the most inconsiderate [ __ ] that
you could possibly do it anytime you
call him on it they always say sorry I
just got a lot of [ __ ] coming up now I
mean it's a lot of stuff is coming up I
don't know I probably get some [ __ ]
letters on that email Stone writes
letters anymore
so anyways he's always been a [ __ ] to
know
oh [ __ ] annoying and arrogant but
recently he [ __ ] my parents for money
my parents felt heartbroken and betrayed
over this I've always hated him and hate
him even more now that he made my mother
cry and made my father angry
in order to stay my father's good graces
he threw my mother and I under the bus
in an email to my dad one day saying
everything was our fault I was glad when
my father finally told him off and said
not to contact me or my mother again
well here's my question how the [ __ ] did
you know that he was a piece-of-shit con
man before they did a few weeks ago I
had to go to my grandfather's birthday
my mom and dad couldn't make it so my
boyfriend and I went alone I didn't
acknowledge my uncle when I said hi to
everyone and kept my distance throughout
the day he kept interrupting any
conversation I was having with other
relatives to make an obnoxious joke
about me or Philly I live in Philly and
loved it
my uncle is from Philly but lives in New
York and now is all about it Yankees
cheesecake and all he trashes Philly all
the time which pisses me off
because he knows I like it there he even
went up to my boyfriend who was wearing
an Eagles hat and started talking [ __ ]
to him she goes yeah I know that might
be justified there everything he did was
rude and disrespectful he never said
hello or asked about my mom and dad when
I left I was angry for days I didn't say
anything to him or call him out so my
question to you bill is should I say
something to my shitty uncle next time
he's always been a loudmouth son of a
[ __ ] but now it's a personal but now
it's personal and [ __ ] rude that he
continues to do it when he knows I know
all this [ __ ] sometimes they think he
still looks at me as this little girl
nice but ba ba ba ba I don't need to
read anymore of this what do you think
any words of wisdom would help love the
podcast thanks in advance well what you
should have said was you should have
announced to the entire party my uncle
is just something just throw his [ __ ]
throw his dirty laundry right out there
just say why are you being rude to me
why are you deliberately being rude to
me right now I know he's weird you can't
lie
call him like a piece of [ __ ]
I don't know but he won cuz he made you
angry and he ruined your day why don't
you just be condescending to him every
time he touched me oh you're adorable
hey who'd you [ __ ] over today you know I
heard they have an old folks home down
the street they like playing checkers
maybe he can play some checkers a titty
little tiddlywinks with them and steal
their money you know just do [ __ ] like
that a good joke from the alcoholic over
here everybody I would just do stuff
like that just throw his [ __ ] right in
his face no you know what you do is you
say all is shipping you just be really
nice oh my god my uncle my favorite
relative who's an alcoholic I I gotta
tell you people out of all the people
who've stolen money from my parents this
guy here is my favorite just do [ __ ]
like that you just keep complimenting
him as you're calling him an absolute
piece of [ __ ] who can't handle their
booze I still love you anyways I just
start drinking a beer right in front of
them oh god damn it is that delicious
hey you want one come on you know you
dope oh that's right you can't handle it
whose little baby then you just pinched
his fat [ __ ] booze cheeks just I
would do two [ __ ] like that just annoy
him back but don't sit there in silence
and let this guy [ __ ] do that to you
you know [ __ ] these levels too goddamn
low too low hello hello
you know I rented that movie to kill a
mockingbird I finally watched that movie
and I gotta be honest with you I don't
get it
I don't get that movie who's supposed to
be the Mockingbird in that because the
way I look at it they killed the
mockingbird you know but then in the end
they act like Robert Duvall character is
the mockingbird he might be another one
but wasn't the guy who was on trial a
mockingbird how come they didn't give a
[ __ ] about him and I don't buy that he
just ran away and then they shot him I
think that that was that race
[ __ ] where they just decided that they
were gonna kill him so then they just
made up that he ran away see this is
what I like to do people to close out
the podcast I like to bring up a movie
that came out Oh 6070 [ __ ] years ago
and talk about it like it came out like
[ __ ] six months ago no Jesus I'm sorry
let's let's finish up here with one last
little advertisement gamefly.com
everybody is that what it's called I
hope it is advertising schedule here we
go here we go gamefly.com everybody if
you like playing video games wouldn't be
wonderful to have 8000 video games 8000
video games at your fingertips that can
be delivered to your door or directly to
your PC alright
for 15 days you get a free trial a
15-day free trial that is a two weeks
and one day where you can access all
8000 of those games for absolutely free
just go-to gamefly.com slash bill burr
click on the microphone and all that
stuff and you you you'll be good you
will be good to go 8000 video games look
at me you know bring the post office
into your apartment the games oh I don't
know what I'm saying anymore did I do
the amazon.com yet that I kind of do
that you guys know the deal at this
point if you want to help my podcast and
give 10% of what I make to the Wounded
Warriors Project just go to
billboard.com click on the podcast and
then in the the corner you'll see the
amazon banner you click on that and then
i'll then just buy whatever you want to
buy on amazon.com they kicked me a
percentage and then 10% of that I give
to the Wounded Warriors Project and
that's it and that's it that's the
podcast for this week everybody how
about those Celtics you know I actually
tried to watch a Red Sox game yesterday
I watched and I don't even know anybody
on the team anymore you know I finally
saw what that Gonzalez guy look like
that we got from the Padres I haven't
watched in I don't know good couple of
years it was June of something oh 9 or
that's when I just said you know what
[ __ ] this I can't watch this [ __ ]
anymore
I just root for them to lose cuz I want
Bobby Valentine to get fired although I
do think it's funny that he tipped his
cap when everyone was booing him I do
think that that's funny but I hate when
people just cause controversy and just
make [ __ ] about themselves when they
haven't accomplished anything did I just
describe my podcast alright maybe on the
Bobby Valentine of podcasting I think
you are I think you are that [ __ ]
annoying
um that's the podcast for this week
everybody um where am I gonna be coming
up why don't why don't I go to Bill burr
calm we'll see what's uh what the deal
is hey can anybody tell me why dogs
sleep so [ __ ] much they'll put it
they won't they'll put in eight hours
and then you take them around the block
and then they sleep for like another
four hours and they get all antsy around
noontime you take them out again and
then they just plop down and then they
have one more burst of energy and then
they're ready to sleep for another eight
hours
isn't that what like all wild animals do
like don't like lines for the most part
just laying around all day you know well
I I guess I gotta go kill something then
they go and they kill something they
[ __ ] gorge themselves and then just
lay around the Sun for the like the next
three days sleeping it's not what they
do you know somebody down the street I
have to whisper cuz somebody down the
street they they bought two giant lions
to have outside their house you know
like the fake lions it basically it just
screams new money you know what I mean
that's like one of the one of the first
things you do like the average [ __ ]
who hits the lottery you know what they
gonna do right they're gonna get a limo
go booze and they're gonna buy a car
maybe pay off one bill right and then
the very next thing they're gonna do is
they're gonna buy two giant [ __ ]
lions to stand guard at the end of the
driveway of their [ __ ] apartment
building I don't know why people do that
but these ones were actually decent they
were actually decent looking all right
here's the upcoming events
I have my next row gig isn't until June
15th you [ __ ] serious
Jude oh I guess I'll be in LA building
up my act the San Jose improv on June
15th and June 16th and on the 17th it
says San Jose improv but we got to fix
that I'm actually gonna be at the
Chicago theater with Steve Byrne Vince
Vaughn and all these other guys I don't
know who else is gonna be there but
that's enough of a show right there
isn't it
June 17th at the Chicago theater oh and
June 15th and 16th I'll also be
performing with chelsea peretti
Sacramento's own chelsea peretti so you
know she's psyched to get up there
that's why she's doing the gig you know
she wants to drive up and go see family
up in Northern California Ontario improv
I played June 29th 30th and July 1st
Hampton Beach ballroom casino going
white trash here people July 14th
then I go to the Newport yachting Center
July 15th and I know what you're
thinking there oh is that the
Illuminati's comedy club no it is not
it's a parking lot with a tent over it
and I'll be performing there with some
sort of makeshift air conditioner
pathetically trying to blow cold air on
my giant forehead and then my triumphant
return returned to New York City
July 26 27th 28th and 29th at Caroline's
on Broadway in New York New York and
then we're into September in football
season and I'm going to be doing cities
that I have never done before like
Orlando eight nine seven eighth and
ninth look at that Orlando Florida
that's it that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves thank you to
everybody who's been listening the
podcast has been growing thanks to
everybody's been going on to amazon.com
gamefly.com and stamps stamps calm
appreciate it I don't know when I'll
ever see any money from any of these
things it's amazing how this advertising
works you know they advertise and then
like nine months later they stay finally
send you a check you know thank you for
your wonderful work hyping the new Palm
Pilot back in 2001 alright that's it is
there anything any [ __ ] I wanted to talk
about any
sports hey Bill who do you like for the
[ __ ] NBA championship anybody but the
Lakers anybody but the Lakers who do I
like for the Stanley Cup I like a lot of
the teams I think a lot of teams that
are playing each other like I like I
sort of like the Capitals I like the
Rangers I like the Flyers I don't like
the Devils I'll never get over that
boring style of play that got them three
Stanley Cups that left-wing lock trap
defense during the clutch and grab error
made me almost abandon the game and for
some reason I blame them when I know
people played that for years so I can't
get into them although I do think it's
funny that they went Oh Stanley Cups
right across the river from [ __ ] in New
York that does make me laugh so in a
pinch if I had to vote vote vote vote
for either that was vote or in route at
the same time if I had a vote for Jersey
or the Rangers that's a tough one
Rangers are just such a legendary Club
even though they haven't they've won one
Stanley Cup in 72 [ __ ] years I still
like him though
I like the fly is I'd like to see the
st. Louis Blues and I would say I'd like
to see the LA Kings if they're [ __ ]
fans weren't also Laker fans you know I
just I don't know I'm so [ __ ] sick
you know you know depressing it was to
go back to Boston and run into the
[ __ ] morons that I did for the most
part I met nice people but just a couple
of those it was just so [ __ ]
depressing because I loved going back to
Boston because as far as a sports fan
I've been I've been behind enemy lines
since when I left in 1995 I went to New
York City and I live in LA so I have had
to deal with Yankee fans Jets fans and
now Laker fans and I just want to go to
a place where I can express affection
for my teams and not have to immediately
get into some sort of [ __ ] debate and
then I go back there and then it's just
that [ __ ] you know and I know now that I
admitted that those things happened in
Boston now I'm gonna get a bunch of
holier-than-thou [ __ ] emails
from people but you have to understand
that I've traveled for 20 years as a
comedian and I've done the third show
Saturday night and and I've talked to
those people so I bring it do you want
to [ __ ] talk down to me why am i
defending bond I can't defend it I can't
defend it but you know I don't know I
don't what the [ __ ] I'm safe all right
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourself I'll
talk to you next week
you